just yesterday she called for the DNC's
head Tom Perez to resign she's with us
live in New Hampshire done in
congresswoman Gabbard how are you good
to see you very nice to see you fellow
Democrats they're afraid to come on the
show I don't know a nice person of guys
Shawn why Perez resign voters in this
primary need to have the confidence that
their votes will be counted and their
voices will be heard and unfortunately
he's had a failure of leadership in
being able to uphold that faith and that
trust we've got a lot of a lot of
primaries a lot of elections between now
and the convention and we need to be
able to get back on track I don't I
could never understand that it was
obvious that the 2016 Democratic primary
was rigged it was rigged against Bernie
Sanders and thought of Brazil when she
took over for debbie Wasserman Schultz I
had to call him one day and say you kind
of got cheated now they want to change
the rules so Oh Bloomberg can get in
debates and they want to change the
rules and let the super-delegates vote
count on the first ballot again to rig
the primary that's your party that's not
my party this is part of the problem and
this was post 2016 where a lot of people
saw the problems with this system with
the super-delegates with how hard it was
for people to actually get out and cast
their votes to get their voices heard
that's driven a lot of the frustration
that I'm hearing from Democrats with
this process today you know it's not
only what happened in Iowa Iowa voters
really lost out in that whole situation
but it's also that decision that all of
a sudden the rules are changed to be
able to benefit this billionaire Michael
Bloomberg and the decision that the DNC
has made throughout unfortunately to try
to hold a pre primary before voters have
even had a chance to go out and cast
their votes there are bigger changes
that we need super-delegates remains a
concern I've been a big advocate for
getting rid of super-delegates
altogether I give Republicans credit for
this they don't have super-delegates
they're trusting that the voters will
make their try think you've been treated
horribly I think you're you're with the
things you've been saying about Hillary
Clinton I support you on I thought it
was courageous just acknowledging a
simple truth
that a president gets to hire and fire
the people that he wants now people that
disagree with actually there's a deeper
issue here that not many people are
talking about which is it's not based on
opinion this is based on the
Constitution you know I'm a soldier I'm
still serving the Army National Guard
Knight thank you very much but as a
soldier and as a member of Congress I
took an oath to our Constitution as does
every member of Congress and it is the
Constitution that provides that our
foreign policy is set by the president
United States as well as in some
significant ways by Congress not by
unelected exec rats and not by the
military and the reason why our founders
had the wisdom in doing this is because
they knew if voters were unhappy with
the foreign policy decisions being made
they could make that decision at the
ballot box to hire or fire whereas they
can't do that with unelected bureaucrats
or others I mean this is what makes you
very unique in your party to be very
honest one you have courageous enough to
come on other shows and you're actually
gonna be seen by people if you go on
those other fake news networks nobody
will really see you but on a serious
note this sticks in my craw we heard Joe
Biden say you're not getting a billion
dollars until you fire a Ukrainian
prosecutor who's investigating his son
who's being paid millions who's on tape
saying that he had no experience in oil
gas energy or Ukraine Congresswoman that
sound good to you I don't know what
those tapes Joe Biden will be held to
the standards an op Ian hopes as voters
make this is my whole point is voters in
this country voters and the Democratic
primaries here in New Hampshire you've
got a lot of independents and
libertarians who are coming out to cast
their votes tomorrow they're gonna make
their decisions based on who they
believe will best serve questions you
could call Donald Trump and say even
though we disagree on some things I want
to work with you on X what would it be
there's a long list I think that was
better there's far more that we need to
do on criminal justice reform I would
loved it I would love to be able to work
with President Trump on ending this
failed war on drew
and I think a first legalized drug start
is by ending the federal marijuana
prohibit you want to legalize all drugs
I think that we need to look to the
model in Portugal you want to
illegalized a model in Portugal where
there has been a decriminalization and
in some heroine its legalization and
regulator one so that we treat substance
abuse and it would you legalize heroin
substance abuse and would you leave
don't make me be a jerk as a health care
issue rather than one where we are
putting more and more heroin would you
legalize or prisons would you legalize
it this is my point we've got to end the
failed war on drugs okay no we can help
dodging we can help people who need help
or rather than putting them in our
prisons but thank you for coming thank
you it's good to see you thank you